- So, you gained weight in space.
- I gained weight. I
really liked the food, man.
It was good.
(laughing)
- I mean, if you had a
pretty much unlimited supply
of macaroni and cheese, Chuck.
- Yeah, but doesn't it come
in, like, a freeze-dried
little pouch?
- Well, it's dehydrated.
- Oh, is that what it is?
- But it's good.
It's macaroni and cheese,
one of my favorites,
that's dehydrated.
Also shrimp cocktail,
shrimp cocktail's excellent.
- Really?
- That I think, I don't know
if you have stats on it,
- Sounds like you guys are
living pretty high on the
hog up there in space.
- Of course we are, yeah.
- I'll have another shrimp
cocktail, thank you.
- Did you ever eat that
astronaut ice cream they sell?
- No.
- Yeah, don't eat that stuff.
- Is that the ... It
looks like cotton candy?
- I don't know what it is,
it looks like cardboard.
- Yes.
- And every once in a while
I'd get coerced into eating it,
for, you know, some
kid thing or something.
(disgusted noise)
We don't eat that stuff in space.
- You guys have actual good food.
- We have really good food, yeah.
Chocolate fudge cake, for
example, is a very good dessert.
If you have this, call it
cardboard, which is what that
ice cream is, or chocolate
fudge cake, you're going
for the chocolate fudge cake.
- Yeah.
- Kids love that astronaut
ice cream stuff, though.
- Yeah, well.
- Kids, man, they'll eat anything.
- Kids are stupid, let's be honest.
- They're eating that
stuff, they love that stuff.
- Kids don't know what they like.
- But adults aren't, you
know, we're not going
to get fooled.
- Well, we've lived.
(laughing)
- Yeah, we know what it's
like not to eat cardboard.
- We've lived.
We know better than to
eat cardboard ice cream.
- Yeah, that's no good.
But the food is really good.
- Wait, so, here's the
thing, because I'm trying to
figure out.
- Yeah?
- Aren't you supposed
to lose weight in space?
- Most people don't gain weight in space.
I was one of only two people.
When I got back after my
first flight, and you get
your physical, and they
take your blood pressure,
of course all your vitals,
and they weigh you,
it was like, "Oh, my god!"
It was like a eureka.
"He gained weight."
They got me in a little bit
heavier than when they put
me on the space ship a
couple weeks earlier.
- How does that happen?
- So, I think there's a
couple, one is that I was in
really good shape when I
left on my space flights,
best shape I was ever in in my life.
So I think I was kind of low.
And then when I got to space,
you don't eat very much.
One reason you don't eat
very much, especially,
is because you don't feel
very good, you don't feel
very well.
You have a bit of stomach
awareness, because your whole
system is getting used to it up there.
Your vestibular system works
on gravity when we're here
on Earth, so it tells us
we're right side up, we're
accelerating, we're moving around.
- Right.
- As we move our head, we're
running, driving a car,
you're accelerating, all
that stuff works in concert
with your eye movements, with your vision.
Now what happens is when
you're in space, and your
vestibular system stops
working because it works on
gravity, your brain gets a bit confused.
- Right.
- Because the vestibular system
is saying you're perfectly
still, but your eyes are
saying you're moving.
So the first couple days
you don't feel very well.
- So do you feel yourself
actually in free fall?
Around the ...
Because you're in free fall, right?
- You are.
You're going around our planet
at 17 500 miles an hour,
but really no sensation of
speed other than, you know,
you look on this watch,
here is California, and then
we hit Miami, and 10 minutes go by.
You know that's going really fast.
- Right.
- Right?
But you don't feel it,
there's no wind resistance,
there is nothing.
It's just, you know, this motion.
- So, how about exercise?
- Yeah.
- Because I thought you
guys had to exercise.
- Maybe that's why I
gained all that weight.
- I thought you had to exercise
while you were up there.
- That's why I gained
all that weight, Chuck.
The issue is, in space, if
you're up there for longer
periods, a couple weeks,
like I was up there with my,
with my astronaut friends,
not that bad if you didn't
exercise.
But we still exercised every
day to feel better, of course.
- Right.
- So every day, if we
weren't space walking,
which is a pretty big athletic event.
- I'm sure that's pretty hard.
- You were doing something
to exercise, mainly riding
an exercise bike, is what
we had on board the shuttle.
These guys on the Space
Station, these men and women
on the Space Station, if
you're up there for that amount
of time that the missions
are currently, six months.
So, picture if you were on
like, super duper bedrest,
meaning you have to do absolutely nothing.
It's even worse than bedrest.
But if you lay down ...
Don't try this, by the way.
But if you laid down
for six months straight
and didn't do anything.
- Oh my god, that's my dream.
- Exactly, but it wouldn't
be such a good idea to get
up right away after those six months.
So when you're up there floating in space,
you're not even using any of your muscles.
No load at all is being
placed on your muscles
or your bones.
By load, I mean no force
to keep them healthy.
- Right, there's no force.
And that's because you're weightless.
- Because you're weightless.
So right now, even what we're
doing, by moving our hands,
by sitting up straight as best we can,
getting up and walking
around a little bit,
we are doing a little bit.
- Right.
- That it keeps us, not
necessarily keeps us in shape,
but it'll prevent us from
being totally deteriorated
after, like you would be in space.
So in space, while you're
doing that, if you're not
doing anything, your body
adjusts to that environment
in that way if you're not doing anything.
So you'll go through bone loss.
Your bones will become much weaker.
- Oh, really?
- And you'll go through
muscle loss, and even your
heart will shrink.
Your heart is a muscle, right?
- Right.
- It's not going to have to
pump as hard if you're just
laying around all the time.
So by exercising, you're
keeping your muscles strong
and your bones strong, and
everything working really well.
And we've gotten pretty good.
The issue with it, though,
is that it requires a lot
of time.
It's a two hour exercise
period every day, six days
a week.
- You're kidding me.
- Every day, six days a week.
- Two hours?
- Yep.
- That's because the
benefits of exercising aren't
as intense because you have
no force enacted upon you?
- Right.
So there's a treadmill, and
there's an exercise bike
on the Space Station.
There's also the
resistive exercise device.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah.
So you get a resistive
exercise, which is like
weight lifting.
- Right.
- And because you can take
600 pounds, and you know,
you and I can just play catch with it.
- Nice.
- Right?
That's a lot, we can't do
that here on Earth, right?
But in space, you won't
have the weights, right?
You have mass, but not weight.
- You have mass, no weight.
- Weight, but yeah, right,
because you need gravity to
actually weigh something.
So, big barbells and dumbbells
aren't going to help you.
So what we use is this
resistive exercise device
which works on springs,
pulleys, kind of like a
thorough band, you know that?
- Resistance band.
- Resistance, exactly.
- Yeah.
- So this allows you to
get a full body workout.
You can do squats and curls
and bench and everything
else like you would, but
you do it with this special
machine.
- Now I just want to go to
space to lift 600 pounds.
Just to bench 600 pounds.
- We moved around, we were
at Space Walk and we handled
these big instruments
weighing 300 pounds like they
were nothing.
You've gotta be careful,
then they get away from you
easily too, so you've gotta
be careful with that stuff.
- We have forces enacted
upon us here on earth.
Why don't they just create that up there?
Like, what was that, 2001 Space Odyssey?
- Yeah, they were rotating around there.
- Rotating to create ...
- That would be cool, right?
But that requires a really big spaceship,
or it requires a lot of room.
I had a friend of mine in grad
school who had this thesis,
when he had his idea, and
the equipment he built was a
centrifuge that you could
sleep on so you wouldn't
waste any time during the day.
And you were spun, it was a rotating bed.
Your head was at the center
of it, so you wouldn't
get this Coriolis effect that
would wig you out, right.
So it would rotate you
and it's that rotation
of sleeping in a centrifuge
and that would put force
on your body and that would help
but that was pretty big man,
that was really big.
- The bed was big?
- The bed yeah, you gotta put a bed
and then it's gotta rotate, you
need a lot of room for that.
- Right, right, right.
- So it's a little impractical.
- So it was like a localized
artificial gravity environment.
- Correct, yeah but if you could produce
an artificial gravity
environment by rotating
them enough, that would
probably be a good idea.
I don't know what that would be like,
I think cause if you're rotating someone,
it was during sleeping but
for a room to be spinning,
I think you need a really big room.
- Or a lot of alcohol.
- A lot of alcohol, then it get worse.
- For the room to be spinning.
- I think you're really need it
cause if we were in a rotating room
I think that would be
a little disconcerting.
- Yeah without a doubt.
So artificial gravity is probably not
something we're gonna see then,
if it takes a huge, huge space station.
- Probably, let's say
figure out a better way
to do it.
The transportation mode
is the other thing,
if you can get places more quickly
then you don't have to
worry about floating around
but when where we get to planets,
even on the moon, you
have one sixth gravity,
Mars you have one sixth gravity,
so you have a little bit of gravity there
which is very helpful
but you gotta be able
to withstand the voyage
there without any gravity
field around ya.
So, on the missions I was
on was going to Hubble
on the shuttle.
- Which by the way, you
repaired the Hubble.
- I did, I was one of those guys.
- It was two of you guys out there
and you were actually..
- Two at a time.
- Yeah, we had four, you
have two space walking teams
and we're out there taking turns going out
five days in a row on both of my missions.
- That's wild.
- Repair man in space.
It's like working on a
car with boxing gloves,
that's pretty much it is.
People ask me astronomy questions,
they ask me, my neighbors,
I'd be putting out the garbage
and they go, "Hey Mike," and I'm like what
and they go, "Tonight,
isn't it true that Mars",
this is like a question for Neil,
"Isn't it Mars is over
here and this the only time
in 300 years that it's over there
and Venus is there and we're
gonna see some other star
come out over there," and
I'm like, "I don't know"
they go, you don't know, I have no idea.
They go, "You worked on
a Hubble, didn't ya?"
I go, "Yeah, I worked, I don't
look through the telescope,
I just fix it."
So, yeah, I was the repair man up there.
- That's so funny.
You're way too modest man, a repair man,
an astronaut repair man,
who gets to say that.
- I can fix almost anything
inside of a space suit,
that's the problem, now
without the space suit
I'm kind of at a loss.
- If you're not wearing a suit
you can't enact your super powers.
- If I wanna fix the sink
I gotta get a helmet on,
I'm so used to doing it.
- Alright, keep your science capsule on
because the spinning doesn't stop here.
For more on weight, mass,
gravity and centripetal force
check out Brilliant's
Centripetal force quiz,
it's part of the
classical mechanics course
that gets into explaining the
core principles of physics
and applies them to real world uses
like rockets and space and space stations
and drones and zero G and more.
If you're the type of person
who hears scientific facts
and wonders, hey, how
did they figure that out,
then Brilliant is right for you,
it walks you through scientific
and mathematical problems
guiding you step by step at your own pace.
So you can sign up for free
at Brilliant.org/Startalk
and get access to weekly
puzzles and brain teasers
but if you're one of the first 782 people
to subscribe to our annual plan,
which gives you access to all the courses
across the variety of subjects,
including outer space and zero G,
You will receive 20% off your annual fee for life.
Oh, do you have a catch phrase, Mike.
- Zippity do da.
(laughing)